immer wenn er weg hat zum frühdienst
könig überlege ich linie zu bleiben und
rechne mir aus ob wir nicht doch zum
leben ausreicht hey ich bin so wie ich
bin 26 jahre alt und ich befinde mich im
dritten ausbildungsjahr zur gesundheits
und krankenpflegerin ich bin vanessa 30
jahre alt und wird ebenfalls in der
ausbildung zur gesundheits und
krankenpflegerin im dritten lehrjahr
[Musik]
wir sind die generation merkel weil sie
16 jahre regiert hat und wir kennen ja
eigentlich keine andere bundeskanzlerin
oder bundeskanzler also vor allem nicht
seitdem wir so ein bisschen politisches
interesse und empfinden haben
[Musik]
vanessa und ich haben uns dazu
entschieden bei instagram über unsere
ausbildung zu berichten als absolut die
motivation dass sich was verändert in
unserem beruf und das geht nur indem wir
aufmerksamkeit schaffen indem er laut
sind uns präsentieren den beruf vor
allem präsentieren und zeigen wie cola
ist
ganz nach links neben stücken wir
nachher
habe darüber
den kopf nochmal leicht zu mir
jetzt ein bisschen der wind drin
es sind ganz viele themen wichtig auch
politisch ist auf jeden fall
berufspolitik ist auch ein großer teil
auf unserem account
[Musik]
625 und
ja meine energie ist noch nicht ganz da
ist es viel zu früh am morgen und auch
viel zu kalt mich also spontan
entschieden jetzt doch mit dem auto zur
arbeit zu fahren und die stadt mit dem
fahrrad
nach dem 19 frühdienst in folge fällt
anders aufstehen manchmal wirklich sehr
schwer man merkt es in jedem knochen
wunderschönen guten morgen ich
darf mich erst mal vorstellen ein
pfleger in der natur abteilung und heute
die hose mit ihnen aber durch hörende
herz natürlich zusammen wir sind für ihr
wohl des schlafens zu stellen ist das
ist
kein wunschtraum muss dafür sind sie
verantwortlich wird dann reisen erlaubt
zugleich und jetzt sogar den strand
reifen wenn sie treiben hier gibt es im
chor da sind sie
treue erste mal bei ihm hab ja schon 400
größe gab es da waren wir so als ob ich
da
seien fünf schiffe im raum schäffner
kommt jetzt wirklich wohl gleich die
kolleginnen und dann nehme das
einschleusen vorher alles klar bis
gleich
es fehlen definitiv auszubildende die
den beruf der pflege ergreifen und vor
allen dingen dann auch in der pflege
bleiben und die meisten verlassen diesen
beruf nach einigen jahren wieder und das
ist ein riesiges problem denn unsere
gesellschaft wird immer älter und das
pflegepersonal immer weniger das ja
seines verhältnis
hier aus dem op plan geht hervor dass
wir hier eine sogenannte orale
informationen brauchen keine nasale
[Musik]
und sie wollen mich in streifen
schneiden
heute nicht
sind sie aufgeregt
war schöpf hierbei ja
[Musik]
wir passen auch genau und sie denken
jetzt
denken sie sich einen schönen traum aus
in der vorbereitung für die op achten
wir darauf dass die kreislauf situation
des patienten stabil ist sprich
blutdruck herzfrequenz und die
sauerstoffsättigung
vanessa pre oxidiert den patienten jetzt
das wird gemacht damit die informationen
möglichst
problemlos vonstatten geht und dann
achten wir einfach darauf dass wir es
den patienten so bequem und ruhig wie
möglich gestalten
das ist eine ausnahmesituation für
patienten
es ist schön wenn man ihnen ein bisschen
beistand leisten kann in dieser
situation
bist du zufrieden
denn ich kann es noch nicht ganz
dann gehen bei dem medikament auch noch
chance richtig anzukommen
[Musik]
ich glaube den meisten menschen ist die
verantwortung die wir letztendlich
tragen nicht so wirklich bewusst und
wenn etwas jetzt nicht wirklich bewusst
ist dann können die menschen das auch
nicht dementsprechend honorieren klar
würde ich mir wünschen dass
gesellschaftlich unsere wichtige rolle
und unsere große verantwortung anerkannt
ist
die probleme in der pflege werden meiner
meinung nach nicht gelöst nur wenn das
gehalt angehoben wird da bedarf es noch
einige mehr punkte die angegangen werden
und dazu gehört zum beispiel auch die
professionalisierung der pflege und auch
dass sich pflege zum beispiel in
gewerkschaften oder berufsverbänden
organisiert
das ist natürlich anstrengend körperlich
sowie mental
und an manchen tagen ist man dann
vielleicht auch nicht mehr so motiviert
wenn man irgendwas noch vorhat und geht
lieber auf die couch und fernsehen ist
was aber es gibt auch tage wie heute da
sind wir motiviert wir freuen uns wenn
die sonne scheint und wir haben nutzen
wir das aus und machen fotos wir können
noch ein bisschen zeit zusammen
verbringen
[Musik]
wenn wir über das mit dem schild was
nehmen zum thema kein der das und
isolation und
soziale
folgen wer oder auch ob mitarbeitende
angst vor keimen haben oder wie es für
sie jetzt ist mit seiner höheren
keimbelastung quasi ich fand aber auch
komponente gut wie
studien oder so sind wie patienten damit
umgehend dass pflegekräfte teilweise
komplett vermummt sind ob die längeres
gefühl gegenüber liegenden haben und
dann wäre natürlich hier so ein bild
nicht schlecht
[Musik]
die schicht heute mit josie war super
wir konnten super viel lernen und wurde
ganz viel gezeigt
[Musik]
ohne marko an meiner seite wäre es
schwer familie und schichtdienst unter
einen hut zu bringen wir teilen uns die
aufgaben einfach sehr gut
[Musik]
ich finde es hervorragend dass nach den
16 jahren frau an der regierung wieder
eine frau zur wahl steht und ich könnte
mir vorstellen dass wenn wir dabei
bleiben bei einer frau und nicht bei
einem älteren weißen mann der sonst wird
das man bestimmt ein paar neue wege
einschlagen kann
guten appetit
nicht in jedem detail stimmigen
videobeweis nicht bist nicht mein
[Gelächter]
als beispiel ist nicht immer
jede führungsposition mit einer frau
besetzt wird
finde ich richtig besetzt nova sie eine
frau ist also das ist natürlich
auch die diskussion über frauenquoten
ich danke herzlich ist wenn männer seien
durch frauen abgelöst werden sondern
einfach dass es ja ich bin also
gemischte teams sind auf den folgen ich
finde auf jeden fall dass es mehr
gleichberechtigung braucht ich will gar
nicht dass jetzt frau die männer ablösen
sondern ich möchte einfach dass es halt
eben zusammen funktioniert dass männer
nicht immer die bessere jobs möglichkeit
haben die besseren mehr gehalt und das
ist einfach mehr aussichten auf eine
führungsposition das finde ich einfach
das muss ausgeglichen sein im kern hat
sie hat sie recht also es ist auf jeden
fall nicht richtig oder wäre nicht
richtig wenn immer nur männer überall in
chefpositionen sitzen würden
ich liebe ist ja wenn sich neue
arbeitsanweisungen ausschließlich an
mitarbeiter richten bin ich als
mitarbeiterin fein raus
der mitarbeitenden im krankenhaus sind
frauen und trotz alledem sind ganz viele
arbeitsanweisungen oder dass da der
mitarbeiter raum ist auf männer gemünzt
dass das geht mir einfach nicht in den
kopf wie da nicht drauf geachtet werden
kann vor allen dingen in einem so frauen
lasst den beruf
für mich die höchste priorität ist und
bleibt momentan das examen und die
arbeit es gibt tage da komme ich vom
dienst oder fällt es mir nicht so leicht
mich anschließend noch hinzusetzen und
zu lernen aber
ich habe den anspruch der sechs haben so
gut es gilt zu bestehen und da muss sich
halt leider die energie aufbringen um
das dann letztendlich zu machen
er war deshalb schon
unfassbares pensum zu erledigen ich
stelle mir das nicht leicht für
ausbildung studium und familie noch
unter einen hut zu kriegen und macht
dinge nie mit metall bei energie
ich muss auf jeden fall für meinen ex am
noch lernen und ich habe auch noch
diverse aufgaben für studium zu
erledigen allerdings ist es jetzt schon
relativ spät und eine konzentration das
jetzt nach dem langen arbeitstag dann
doch nicht mehr so gut und deswegen habe
ich mich dann doch für instagram
entschieden da muss die muss der fokus
nicht mehr so ganz und sein wie dann zum
beispiel beim schreiben einer hausarbeit
die meiste aufregung hat ein post
gebracht da habe ich über das verhalten
von pflegekräften gesprochen wie
motivierend oder vielleicht auch
demotivierend das manchmal auf
auszubildende wirkt nicht demotivieren
da und bringt ein mehr ins grübeln ob
diese ausbildung wirklich das richtige
ist als das gejammer und die resignation
des personals da kommt man als
auszubildender auf eine neue station und
schon vor dienstbeginn schaut man in
müde abgekämpft und genervte gesichter
der erste kaffee ist noch nicht ganz
gibt ausgetrunken darf ein bereits
aussagen wie ich habe keinen bock auf
die scheiße hier ihr die examinierten
kräfte seid unsere vorbilder seid euch
dieser macht bewusst und versucht uns
auszubildenden eine positive einstellung
gegenüber diesen beruf zu vermitteln
darauf gab es viele kommentare positive
wie auch negative also man macht sich
mit solchen aussagen nicht unbedingt
beliebt ja
ich bin mir noch nicht ganz sicher ob
die neue regierung sich traut die
probleme im gesundheitswesen anzugehen
dass wir mehr personal haben dass wir
mehr zeit haben unsere patientinnen so
zu versorgen wie wir es uns wünschen und
wie sie es sich wünschen die
verantwortung mehr anerkannt wird
noch mehr von generation merkel gibt es
hier in der mediathek